[Music]
one of mathematicians have long ago
proposed that the nucleus of a massive
atom contains particles they call
neutrons the mathematicians illustrate
these neutrons just like they do their
protons as tiny bowling balls they
justify the sleight-of-hand on the basis
that protons and neutrons weigh about
the same more precisely a neutron weighs
just about as much as a hydrogen atom a
proton bowling ball and an electron golf
ball put together to distinguish these
two bowling balls the mathematicians
place a little plus sign on the right of
the proton and a zero on the neutron the
positive sign indicates that the proton
is positively charged the zero indicates
that a neutron has no charge it is this
vague unspecified mysterious charge
thingy that allegedly keeps the
negatively charged electrons bound to
the proton neutrons lack this mystical
mediator of attraction but until the
quantum mathematician can tell you what
this magical charge thingy is in
physical terms and how this charged
entity or medium physically mediates the
attraction between protons and electrons
we certainly cannot understand what it
is that the neutron is lacking what is
physically different between a proton
and a neutron why does one have charge
and the other one doesn't if both are
made of quarks which throw gluons at
each other let's zoom in on one of the
protons it is composed of three quarks
two up quarks and one down quark moving
around very close to each other
the quarks are kept together by a number
of gluons interaction with the quarks
and also with the other gluons the
gluons give rise to the gluon field that
keeps the constituents of the proton
together how does this proton
architecture attract a negative electron
does the electron have a hook like shape
that latches on to a ring like proton or
is it a rubber band that binds them in
other words we need to answer how the
properties and behaviors of protons and
neutrons are related to their
architectures thread theory proposes
that light is mediated by an entity that
resembles a twined two-strand rope the
robe Forks out at the surface of the
atom one strand of the rope continues
straight and forms the proton an urchin
like star at the center of an atom the
other thread of this rope coils around
and weaves the electron shell a balloon
that encapsulates the proton this model
enables us to visualize the phenomenon
the mathematicians called charge we can
now understand why an electron is
physically bound to a proton an electron
is not a bead that orbits the atom as
quantum would have you believe the
electron is a balloon we by countless
threads that fork out at the surface of
the electron shell the electron can't
leave the proton even if it wanted to
because it is interwoven with and thus
bound permanently to it an atom expands
and contracts the so-called quantum
jumping torques the rope the torquing of
the rope is what we call light the radio
release and reeling of all these links
of rope is what the quantum
mathematicians have always referred to
as energy when the atom expands and
contracts it also causes a tiny friction
the sliding and rolling of one strand
along the other everywhere the ropes
fork out which occurs almost everywhere
along the surface of the electrons
Kjell the aggregate of this friction is
what the quantum mathematicians call
charge thus an atom has charge at its
surface and releases energy
Einstein's mystical equation finally has
a physical interpretation the rope
torques in two directions to and from
every atom in the universe this
disturbance of the Rope is what we
detect as light traveling at 300,000
kilometers per second thus energy
consists of links of rope released and
reeled at the speed of light in two
directions to and from every atom in the
universe
now quantum mathematicians instead still
hold on to the Ptolemaic notion that
this signal consists of one-way
particles they call photons
with the astrologers of the religion of
quantum mechanics cherished the most are
predictions so here's a prediction for
them the rope model of light and the
atom predicts neutrons if every rope in
the universe converges upon an atom
these ropes must also criss cross in
countless regions where they pass under
way to atoms
the rope hypothesis proposes that this
intersection of ropes constitutes a
neutron under the rope model of light
whereas a proton is a convergence of
electric threads a neutron is a
convergence of electromagnetic ropes an
atom produces charged by rubbing or
rolling the electric and magnetic
threads where they fork out the neutron
lacks the architecture necessary you
perform this function here we have drawn
a red dashed line merely to show where
the atom would end thus although the
weight of the neutron in the atom are
about the same they have different
architectures they're structured
differently
one more time for those who didn't catch
it the first time the magnetic thread
Forks out and weaves the electric shell
the electric thread continues straight
to the center of the atom Quantum
Jumping produces a friction at this fork
everywhere along the surface of the
electron the mathematician referred to
this buzzing all along the surface of
the atom as charged the neutron lacks
the ability to generate description
because it is comprised only of ropes
heading towards atoms thus unlike the
atom the neutron has no charge let's
look now at have neutrons are
incorporated into atoms
[Music]
you
[Music]